at 7:49 a.m. on July 14 2015 the New
Horizons probe got the best look at
Pluto and its moons to date seeing a new
world for the first time I mean that's
huge and Pluto did not disappoint Pluto
is a really weird and phenomenal and fun
place we've seen evidence of basically
ice volcanoes on Pluto things that have
never been seen elsewhere in the solar
system mountains of solid water ice that
are floating on nitrogen seas enormous
basins and activity and mountain
building things that we did not affect
the sea in this tiny tiny world in the
outskirts of the solar system it's
amazing to look at at this world and
realize that I've been staring at it for
years through a telescope and all that
detail was there but below the
resolution level that we could see New
Horizons journey to Pluto began when it
launched back in 2006 over the next nine
and a half years the piano sized probe
flew five billion kilometres across our
solar system this year it finally
reached its icy destination we have a
healthy spacecraft we've recorded data
of the Pluto system and we're outbound
from Pluto
beyond Pluto its moons twirl and tumble
like whirling dervishes with orbits
unlike any seen in our solar system with
a Hydra in particular spinning like a
top rotating 89 times every time it
traverses a one-way time around the
planet that's completely unprecedented
and we really don't understand that
scientists definitely expected Pluto to
be weird just not this weird I think
it's just a much richer and more
interesting than we thought we would
actually see in the beginning no matter
what you predict about Pluto's next it
always seems that it's something even
more bizarre than you had in mind this
year Pluto seemed to capture everyone's
imagination whether they were in the
control room during July's flyby or
following on social media at home its
reclassification gave it kind of an
underdog status and people were rooting
for it everybody knows what it was like
to be kicked off the softball team when
they were 8 years old Pluto being
demoted and also being kind of weird and
strange and far away all of that just
meant there was a lot of anticipation
you ask people what's their favorite
planet even before we had this thing
called dwarf planets and a lot most
people said Pluto and Pluto's spotlight
isn't dimming nASA has only seen a
fraction of the data from New Horizons
we've only seen 20% of the data so 80%
to go who knows what's going to show up
in that 80 percent we actually have not
seen most of the highest resolution data
that we're going to get Pluto sharpest
portrait is still to come
you